Another Day, another instance of Donald Trump's
swamp filling cronyism.
Donald Trump has selected Kelly Knight craft
as the next u s ambassador to the United Nations,
replacing Nikki Haley who bailed out on Trump
last year. The U S Senate has confirmed her
and it just so happens that she was a VIP
guest of Donald Trump's Trump international
hotel. What a surprise, right? She used to
be ambassador to Canada while she was listened
to this, she made 29 visits to Donald Trump's
hotel. She was outside of Canada, 58% of the
time that she was ambassador to Canada and
she stayed at Donald Trump's hotel so often
that she achieved what's called gold level
membership status in the Trump card rewards
program. She really got beyond gold level
rewards. She got herself an ambassadorship
from staying at Donald Trump's hotel so often.
Can you even imagine the Trump card rewards
is the sort of, it's a pyrrhic victory. Even
if you win the Trump card rewards game, you
really lost in some kind of broader existential
sense.
And we heard from Democratic Senator Bob Menendez,
who just straight up called this out for what
it is. He said to senators, don't vote to
confirm her, uh, rampant absenteeism, conflict
of interest, and the Republicans just don't
care. We were told during the campaign that
Donald Trump would end the swamp. He would
stop the revolving door of cronies coming
in and out. He would appoint people who have
qualifications rather than his friends. And
it's all a lie. I mean, I guess, okay. He's
not just appointing his friends. He's also
appointing really good customers of his in
the hotel business. So in that sense, I guess
he is not just or merely appointing friends.
I have a question for the Trump is to watch
the David Pakman show or listen to the show.
Can you defend this nomination? Seriously?
Okay. If you think this is good, if you think
this is anything other than cronyism, get
in touch via email or send me a tweet at Dee
pacman.
How do you defend it? And here's, let me give
you a hint. If you're defensive, this nomination
is men going to mention Hillary Clinton or
Barack Obama. It's not a good one. If you're
defensive, this nomination is going to mention
the Hillary Clinton Foundation or I'm sorry,
the Clinton Foundation or Hillary Clinton's
emails. It's not a good defense. Okay. What
I want to hear from you is tell me exactly
how this is a qualified person who should
be ambassador and how this is anything other
than the exact just exact type of cronyism
that Donald Trump told us he was going to
be rooting out. I don't see any way. And what
it fundamentally comes down to in the end
is that this is just politics as usual. Uh,
despite what we were told was going to be
different and this is why, you know, whenever
you have a candidate who comes in and says,
based on my different background, I will be
completely different as a politician.
This is what a lot of people don't understand.
The reason that we end up with the status
quo politicians once they are politicians
is the system forces them into that. This
is not a defensive Donald Trump. Donald Trump
was particularly corrupt and caroneous stick,
but let's say we believe, imagine for a second
that Donald Trump came from the business world
but not the corrupt crony capitalist business
world. Like let's just say he was a respectable
business person and he says, I'm not going
to do the revolving door of lobbyist elected
official corporate stuff. I'm not going to
do that. I'm not going to hand out ambassadorships
to people who are customers of mine. He might
have really said that. Honestly in Trump's
case it wasn't true, but then the system allows
for and encourages for people to do that.
So a lot of times it's sort of like a chicken
egg thing.
Do we have the corrupt crony capitalist system
that we have because the people who we elect
already have those predispositions or does
the system mold and craft those people into
becoming that regardless of what they were
when they got elected? It's probably a combination
of both, but the challenge stands if you think
this is a reasonable nomination on the merits
that I want to hear from you at Deepak. Man
on Twitter. The show is also on Twitter at
David Pakman show. Follow me, follow the show,
follow everybody. We'll take a quick break
and be back right after this, the